Bộ tưởng nhất bạn, O.C. của RU-Xiva Chion, ngày 18, khẳng định sẽ không tử trước.
Mắc bỏ các đồn đoạn sau cuộc bầu cử thường viện mà Linh mình cầm quyền dã hài đảng,
là dân chủ tự giò LLDP và công mình không dành được đa số vẻ.
Tuyên bố công I.C. và được đường dàng sau cuộc gặp với các lệnh đạo chủ trốt của đảng dân chủ tự giò LLDP.
Chông đó có kỳ tụi tưởng Kisi đà phù miêu và tổng thực ki, Hiroshi Morijama,
phát biểu tại họ báo sau cuộc gặp, ông I.C. và Nhân Mạnh sẽ tiếp tục đạm nhận báo cho tụi tưởng,
nhằm chẳng tạo ra khoảng trộng trình chi ý thời điểm nhìn tay.
Đông thời tập trung xử li các bạn này có bác của đất nước,
như thỏa thuật thế quan, của đại được với Mỹ,
liều của thịt anh hưởng đến hơn lũng nghĩ mà hạn xe khấu của sự mắt trên mọc.
Nói ra, thù tưởng I.C. và cũng cảm kế chính phủ sẽ phản lình nghiêm tốt,
và nỗ lực bảo vệ dẫn nghiệp của nhiều đời sống người dân.
Sống hồ của các liên đạo các cao trong đảng,
ở lời đếp, được xem là YouTube quan trọng giúp ông I.C. và cùng có vị trí và vừa qua ra đoạn khó khăn hiện nay.